welcome to nerve a game like truth or
dare - the truth Watchers pay to watch
players play to win cash and glory are
you a water or a player are you a
watcher or a player are you a watcher
player watch player it's cool right it
looks very sketchy is this legal fee
life is passing you by you need to take
a few risks every once in a while I do
take risks okay you're playing here to
accept your Derby kiss a stranger for
five [ __ ] just kiss that guy
okay okay bye apparently the watchers
want me to team up with you I don't
think I'd make a very good partner study
let's see what else happens okay
Hevy you know where I can find this
dress
my wallet my clothes everything's gone
oh my stuff has gone to go come on nacho
look we don't have a choice
technically it just says we have to
leave the store
big fan hold on I'm just doing the why
and daddy what he's kidding Dada billion
no some kid died in Seattle twinners
what happens if I bail you lose
everything all of our money is missing
leave my wife
officer I need help we don't do this
Hajin I mean what hell is going on
waters they stole our identity we became
prisoners of the game Hey
we control your life the only way honest
to win I remember you're my eyes No
players showing us your weapons failed
at what mattered most
huh yes I know I'm late you've gotta be
here and you have to bring an
exceptional gift